هذا النوع من التناغم لا يحدث هذا النوع من
التزامن
فقط ، نعم هناك اتصال عاطفي عميق
نعم هناك اتصال غير لفظي ،
نعم
هناك رابط توارد خواطر قريب ، ولكن
هناك أيضًا المزيد من الرسائل النصية التي
تصل في وقت ما حوالي الساعة 5 و
13 صباحًا.  يقول:
لا يجب الخلط بين البحرية والبيج من قبل الرمال والبحرية أو
البحرية جدًا ، فإن طلبي للمسيرة الصباحية
يرتدي وفقًا لذلك هناك خصوصية مذهلة
تنورة خضراء خضراء خضراء أكثر أخضر
كيلي أخضر اليشم الأخضر فقط اليشم
الزمرد والأخضر النعناعي أعتقد أننا
واضحون
هنا أيضًا  طبق فاكهة سارتوري بشري ،
طماطم ، بطيخ ، برتقال ، توت
العليق ، قرع التوت العميق
، وقم بإنهائه بشرب الخوخ
أو ربما بعض النبيذ أو أحمر الخدود
وحول موضوع أحمر الخدود ، ما الذي من
المفترض أن أفعله
بهذا الدليل التشريح غير المتجسد هذا
pg-13 إخفاء  الأطفال والاستيلاء على محامٍ يُعد
مسار
خلاصتي النصية بمثابة تذكرة ذهاب فقط إلى
الموارد البشرية ،
ولكنه أيضًا تعليم لا تترك فيه
شيئًا
للصدفة  د القليل من الخيال من
معصم الكتف وجزء غير معروف من خصري
، من يمكن أن تكون نفاياته غيرك فقط
ستكون
واضحًا جدًا لذا فإن تقديمه مفيد جدًا في
الفهم وهذا هو السبب في
أنه من الجيد في النهاية أن هذا ليس مونتاجًا
لأجزاء جسدي ولا يحتاجها أحد  لأرى
كاحلي أو رقبتي أو مرفقي ولكن أيضًا
لأكون صريحًا هذا الصباح قلبي
الذي انكسر قليلاً حتى
لو كنت تتحرك على بعد بضع ساعات
فقط ، سأشتاق إليكم جميعًا
بألوان زاهية
كل ما تبذلونه من ظلال رائعة  من أرجواني
إلى أرجواني حتى يفصلنا اللون الأحمر ،
لذا نعم جيدًا اليوم ، أنا لست أزرقًا فحسب ، بل
لون أزرق للغاية ،
محظوظ جدًا ، لقد كان شرفًا لي أن أجلس
بجانبك لأستمتع بقوس قزح الخاص بك ، حسنًا ، كان هذا
رائعًا
يا جون يا إلهي أنت  يعني أننا لا نحقق
هدفًا نهائيًا مع جون ،
فنحن لا نقوم بعمل جيد ، لا لقد خدعتني